hi this is a science hangout from
science mission I from science mission
so today we have a doctor Chris depth
man associate professor of biology from
University of Virginia because dr.
Chapman has published several
outstanding work in very prominent
journals also he is in the editorial
board of several journals and as reward
has been divided several transferring
he's asked in 2016 he won all University
Teaching Award from University of
Virginia in 2015 he was named cavalli
frontiers fellow 39 footing he was a
maid of honor faculty pain he won a
heartful foundation at foundation
individual medical researcher ball 2011
you and point for excellence in science
and technology junior faculty grant from
university of virginia so these are some
of the few of our see one that the deaf
man welcome dr. document design Sangha
oh thanks for much appreciate da the
invitation let's talk about your
background your education can you talk
something about a little bit about your
background and education enough sure
sure so I grew up in Michigan I was born
and raised in ann arbor kind of in the
shadow of University of Michigan I
didn't up going to university of
michigan i ended up going to western
michigan university but throughout high
school I kind of sought out a bunch of
different experiences including working
for an ambulance company and what I
found was that I didn't actually enjoy
dealing with the patients but I really
liked science behind what we were doing
and so that drew me to study science at
Western Michigan University
and I was fortunate to get an
undergraduate research position and
studied you know signal transduction you
know how cells talk to each other in the
context of toxicology and so I at that
point I just really liked signaling and
so when I graduated from Western
Michigan University I went to Purdue
University which had a really strong
Cancer Center and a bunch of people
working on really interesting signal
transduction mechanism cell-cell
communication and so so there I was
working on how basically zipper
transcription factors could influence
viral progression epstein-barr virus
immune cell development and in cancer
formation in the context of signal
transduction I finished up that work
graduated with my with my PhD in
biochemistry molecular biology and I was
like well you know I still really love
signal transduction so but I want to
learn something different and so what is
the kind of emerging field what's what's
really exciting and so then I went to
Johns Hopkins study with David kinky and
he works on today you know work on the
development of the novices but really
what caught me was the fact that these
neurons are really really long and you
can actually start a signal down here
and watch what happens down at the cell
bottom so this idea that you can
separate signal transduction means it's
like the perfect system to study
everything that I'm really interested in
and so that's kind of how I got there so
this little high school in the shadow of
Ann Arbor to Western Michigan University
which is a smaller college to Purdue to
John Hopkins now here are you lose your
virginity so do you have any little
models like mega to help you throat
you'll edit video yeah you know I really
all of the mentors that I could have
been amazing and I it's really humbling
to think about you know their generosity
and everything they've done for me
starting with my undergraduate research
advisor Leonard Ginsburg my graduate
mentor Elizabeth koprowski to my postdoc
mentor David guilty they've all been
incredibly incredibly generous with me
and you know I feel like you know I'm
really kind of standing on the shoulders
of giants not only in terms of building
on the science that we all develop
together but also you know passing on
that spirit of generosity to the people
that I mentor yeah so I think actually
that that's a really important question
and to mentor sorry okay i know i know
you had a busy person being an SS a
puppet uh you knew that I can't get
money pick it up the project and uh so
that I want to figure out you what have
your updates and eat this well so I
really love to cook you know like
cooking is not so different than
biochemistry no I kind of cooked the
different ingredients in you gotta
balance the acid and the basic and the
salt and to make something taste amazing
i think visitors also really interesting
neuroscience component when you're
chasing something delicious but and it's
a poking like this memory of your
childhood or something like that it just
creates this kind of powerful experience
so i think everything about cooking is
fascinating I'm i like i don't i don't
do this very often anymore but I used to
really like to play poker no cards I
think that kind of psychological aspect
and the math half couple with math
aspects is really interesting I love
books a little movies like hanging at
home with the dogs I can this one
not that and let's talk about to a lab
and lab people so can you give us little
bit overly of your lab and the guys
playing those dogs how do you interact
with them enough yeah so right now we
have between six and eight grad students
and the reason it's fuzzy is because
there's a couple komentar graduate
students and that's something I'm really
enjoying more and more where one grad
student is both in my lab and sequences
lab so we have one student preview is in
my lab and somebody else's lab you
studies endosomes and then we've got
another one another graduate students in
my lab company in biomedical engineering
who's finding really interesting ways to
come measure multiple multiple things at
once by like flow cytometry so we can
actually measure 50 markers
simultaneously and we think this is
going to really help us to rapidly
assess what's going on and different
models like that so between six and
eight grad students got a couple
postdocs 11 manager who saved my bacon
on a daily basis she's collaborating
he's awesome a senior lab researcher who
kind of helps everybody along with bio
chemistry experiments and things like
that and then you know I'm part of our
missions this is an undergraduate
University City butter bread so we
always had kind of rats in the first
year and they're usually with us so
we've got about 50 undergrads so what
was actually wrong let's talk about that
he said in any particular look like what
Olivia clicking on the new designs new
development um yeah sure I think and I
think we're going to get into this and a
little bit i can give you some slides
but basically the idea my lab is that i
am really interested in how the nervous
system is assembled during development
and in particular i'm interested in the
rules underlying that assembly of the
nervous system
you know we've got billions and
trillions of synapses but only
twenty-three thousand and so
understanding those oh so every
connection can't be bark they're
actually has to be kind of a general
organizing principle and the organizing
principle that we talked about a lot we
think about a lot is competition so
competition for I mean everything is
over produced and some neurons persists
that survived and other neurons die if
they're not connecting karma this
happens for axons and synapses and
things like that Oh by understanding
that basic principle underlying nervous
system development we're interested all
that we're starting to apply that to
diseases so things like metabolism pain
disorders axon degeneration both in the
context of like spinal cord injuries but
also almost timers disease and
Parkinson's so yeah we get kind of a
broad view of of everything but it is
funded look let's see what presentation
so let's see if I can figure this up
with screen share and I'm gonna go ahead
and I'm going to go ahead and patient
Monday okay good yea big so perfect oh
okay my key word here so I'm going to go
ahead and just play those yeah okay okay
so essentially we're as i mentioned
we're twisting the rules governing the
assembly and the disassembly of the
system basically our big question is how
the nervous system assembled and we've
got this problem that we have to achieve
complexity with
information and so as such we have to
reduce reuse and recycle the genes that
use and so the rule that we think about
a lot of competition as I mentioned so
this this idea is actually kind of old
and this is a one of the only biological
papers done by Alan Turing and he was
kind of the was really critical for
winning World War two and the father of
artificial intelligence but he didn't
write one biological paper kind of
mathematical mathematical modeling how
two opposing morphogens can cause pet
information complex PAP information on
almost anything this is pretty relevant
to biological systems the only catch
here is that these two more pigeons had
have very different Dickinson
coefficients so later on these two
scientists meinhardt and gear came along
and they said well actually we can make
we can build in some different feedback
loops we can get even a greater
diversity of patterns formed and then we
don't need these we don't need very
different diffusion coefficients we get
out diffusion properties very similar to
each other and so that's kind of where
we started and so when you think about
it if you look at it around nature you
see these common patterns in nature
lightning strikes the arbor of a tree
fried riverbeds purkinje neuron in the
in the cerebellum and this is all this
this can all be explained by this thing
that first Turing and then meinhardt
gear but forward where we can have kind
of the self activation and lateral
inhibition of to kind of opposing
morphogens now in this case obviously
you know if you're talking about a
biological system we're going to
opposing signaling pathways or something
like that but in the case of trees or
sand dunes or river beds or things like
that the forces are going to be
different there going to be things like
wind and water drying so we're applying
this idea to several questions one is
thinking about competition
the languor of a system assembly so we
think about this in the context of
survival everything is over produced
neurons acts on synapses and then
refined back and in in effect they
compete with each other we think about
this in terms of axon growth and
guidance axon patterning and the targets
of done there's a heart synapse
formation branch elimination and all
this kind of comes together it could
create a functional circuit let me call
this systems matching on the other hand
we think about how these properties can
be hijacked kind of like in cancer to
give us a normal function or disease
like degeneration which isn't going to
be what I'm going to talk about today
sensory perception or even fat
metabolism okay so if we think about
this activation inhibition paradigm in
the context of a population it's easy to
think about how we can get pattern
formation we've got some winners and
losers but to really understand this we
actually have to look at the level of
the equal to do so at the level of the
individual this could be a synapse a
cell or a tax on we've got a balance
where sometimes the activation wins over
the inhibition these two opposing
morphogens and when the activation wins
over the inhibition will get survival
synapse formation axon worth or increase
in metabolism sometimes you'll have
balance between the two take the
excitability burner on and sometimes
inhibition is going to where you're
going to get cell death synapse
restriction axon degeneration etc so
let's stick into activation first where
activation one's really start to assign
you know which particular pathways are
associated with these feedback loops
because right now we're dealing with us
totally in the abstract so this is
really kind of a classic experiment done
by one of my scientific heroes really
neat really people like I can't see the
side moving you can't see the side
moving yeah okay let's see let's see oh
it's good now yeah can you stop
I can see the slide the next leg oh can
you see this one yeah so this is my my
hero originally montalcino and Victor
hamburger two heroes they did this
really critical experiment which really
informed how we think about nervous
development and took it a chick growing
in an egg take a chicken bring in an egg
maybe you can actually cut out a little
window of that egg and you can actually
take off a little piece of the embryo
where the limb would come out if you
learn section through the spinal cord
you can come and see okay well earlier
on there's lots of motor neurons and
then later on if I on the side where I
cut off the limb others you know ninety
percent of the motor neurons are missing
on the side with the lemon tact only
fifty percent are missing on the other
hand they did another experiment where
they add an extra member and they see
that on that side there's only twenty
five percent of the neurons missing but
on the control side there's fifty
percent so this told us several things
number one neurons are over produced and
this is going to be a theme everything
epic remember system early on I target
right back there exists an implicit in
this idea is the notion of competition
so a factor that they ended up binding
that is responsible for these types of
behaviors is a factor called nerve
growth factor and rita levi-montalcini
and stanley cohen won the nobel prize
for this and here they're taking next
plan of of hunks of neurons and they see
that in the presence of ngf you get this
beautiful halo of axons and a lot of not
survive but in the absence there's
nothing ngf binds to a receptor tyrosine
kinase it's a member of a family of
growth factors bdnf we think we hear a
lot about in the context of depression
and anxiety and things like that ND
three NT 4 are also structurally the
nail bind to specific
receptor tyrosine kinase now this is
this is kind of the field that I get
really excited about thinking about
signal transduction and how cells
communicate with each other but I don't
want to blow the audience away with
intracellular signaling but I thought
but I instead I just want to distill
this down to this basic question this is
actually what got me into neuroscience
first place how do we actually have any
upcoming specifically from a target
transduce transmit a signal all the ways
of the cell body mugs & rehab track a
single princes and it turns out that ngf
is coming from targets like the heart or
the eye or the salivary gland or fat and
it can then internalize this entire
complex into this end ozone okay so
think about like packing your entire
family up into a station wagon you're
bringing all your favorite stuff with
you and then you [ __ ] you get on the
road your car is the dining dine act and
you get on the road which is the
microtubules and you can't get all the
way to California with all of your stuff
so that's all these things like p85 plc
gamma graphing the kindness you get
closer than the nucleus and you activate
transcription and actually here's here's
another way to look at it so ngf coming
from the target this is a nice bigger
done by Bill Snyder and magic a new room
and basically yeah if they don't see
that slam you think about okay okay so
may I smell like it I sometimes have to
click off the full screen I've been good
a bit okay okay so in this case instead
of activating transcription to promote
survival the NGF truck and signalling
endosome can go into the dendrite to
promote synapse formation so clustering
of the postman density all the
neurotransmitter receptors and then
that's sufficient to drive presynaptic
specialization this is based on a paper
that we published a few years ago ok so
we've also found proteins that are
associated with the the signaling and is
a corona one
is one of them and it's really important
for this kind of survival effect in this
competition for survival okay so that's
the activation we've got track a and
kernan on one side what about the
inhibitory side so for this it seems
like that in terms of this p75 it's a
member of the two persons factor
receptor classes family and basically
anything the tracking is doing or track
be p75 is usually doing the opposite at
least in the sympathetic carcasses and
so we're thinking a lot about these
interactions though so on one side ngf
track a and on the other side p75 in
sensory neurons this this relationship
changes its p75 track a on one side tnf
receptor on the other which is a close
cousin of p75 and non peptidergic
sensory neuron uncle correct on one side
and we're not exactly sure what's on
your inventory side and then in
proprioceptive neurons and runs that
kind of comes four buttons position and
time and space we have a track see on
one side TMF on the other we also see
this phenomenon called reverse signaling
with the ligand actually signals back
into the cell I won't believe it was too
much okay so that's kind of the
groundwork for how we think about the
Assembly of the nervous system what I
asked want to talk about is the distance
disassembly of the nervous system and
how we think about degeneration okay so
degeneration isn't always bad in fact
most of the time it's good we don't have
degeneration then we can't form a
functional nervous system everything has
ever produced booth way more axons than
we need and we actually have to sculpt
these back to make a functional services
and so that's what we see in
developmental branch elimination but
sometimes though the more popular the
more I'm not popular but the more
well-known aspects of degeneration are
from either injury like if you get my
spinal cord accident or
from neurodegenerative disease like
Alzheimer's Parkinson's Huntington's
okay so let's talk about like this Oh
black site I could I just see the end
yet slide oh yeah okay here we go okay
so let's talk about the developmental
side first so during development axons
can sometimes send out multiple multiple
branches to different targets and it
turns out that if you have a little bit
better connection over to one target
than the other so like it here I'm
showing more ngf than the other side
will get the the side with less MGF
disintegrating and what we know is that
that antagonistic receptor p75 is
required for this so if we'd not go up
in so many fives we don't get this at
all and so that actually fits nicely
with our account activation versus
inhibition carbine and that's what we
see here we also know that p75 is part
of a family at least in this sympathetic
nervous system which controls our
fight-or-flight response it's one of
three that are primarily expressed tnf
receptor one is the other one as
receptor sixes it is the other and we
see that they're all clustered in the
same clad in the spinal of genetic tree
out of 20 17 of our family member so
highly similar all expressed in the
sympathetic nervous system we see that
so so we wanted to look at these other
factors and so we looked at sensory
neurons and so what you can see is that
the absence of tina far these are of our
knockout animals or the ligand for TFR
is tnf come across this factor you see
that we get tons of axons going into the
pot and these excellent these mice
actually experienced quite a bit of pain
because they're producing way too many
axons also there are two Slovenian
colleagues have shown that dior six is
required for developmental degeneration
as well and that's on the bottom panel
it is ducking keynesian oh it seems like
they okay no I go okay so in the context
of development we've got try
okay curses all of these teen of our
family members okay what about in the
context of something pathological like
acute injury do the same rules apply
well it turns out that there's no
receptors that have been described
former injury induced the generation so
this would be really strange there's
actually quite a bit known about
injury-induced degeneration which is
also called hilarion to generation we
know that there's a metabolite called
nad that is rapidly depleted and that
seems to be quite important for
degeneration because if we actually over
produce this this compound anything we
can preserve these accidents for quite a
bit of time it seems like this protein
SARM is responsible for chopping up
energy and so we know that if we knock
outs are we can preserve axons after
injury and this seems to be going
through some other pathways that
ultimately lead to degeneration and
there's all these kind of interesting
feedback loops going on here but sauron
was actually first identified as
something that's associated with the
receptor for toll-like receptors and so
in the context of injury there's never
been a receptor shown to be associated
with SARM they think that this is
totally happening within the axon they
just kind of self destruct okay but if
we go back to our developmental model we
know that there's there are receptors
involve there so where is the disconnect
here you know are there actually
similarities between these two types of
degeneration and so that's a question
can we get the similar balance between
receptors these cell surface receptors
in the context of victory that's never
been described and I just want to take a
second to acknowledge all the people
that have done this work this recently
came out in Current Biology a few weeks
ago and I think this is going to be here
an area of research for us in the future
okay so let me just tell you a little
bit about the experimental setup oops
happen to my thing ok so the
experimental setup we grow lay down can
you see it no ok let's see
you say no yeah yeah how about no yeah
no I can see ok so we grow some of the
cards and micro fluidic devices think of
these as microchips for neurons okay
they grow across these little micro
brews and so we can in effect separate
the cell body and the axon okay we can
either deprive these guys of nerve
growth factor which is going to elicit
kind of a developmental degeneration
type thing which is also very similar to
Alzheimer's type to generation or we can
take an aspirating pipe cut and a vacuum
and just vacuum off the cell bodies and
leave the axons intact and this would be
like a motorcycle motorcycle accident or
something like that so this is what the
injury looks like we can just rip off
those cell bodies and you can kind of
see on the right hand side the axons
remain intact after we rip off out the
cell bodies we can throw those neurons
these plates back into the incubator and
just essentially watch how long it takes
for these axons to generate and so this
is essentially what will count will
stand for something in the cytoskeleton
like microtubule and will basically look
for things that are beating or and
bluffing and if they've got more than
one or two beats of blobs we count that
as to generate so for example in this
picture we would come please consider
the sense this ninety percent to
generate because there's one of these
boxes that has one bead which we
wouldn't consider degenerated that's how
we come we can also reap also figured
out how to automate this and so this is
an example of like healthy axons we've
got software that can automatically scan
this and then we can throw this into a
program that can automatically assess
degeneration this isn't quite ready for
prime time yet but thought it was so
we're still kind of counting by hand
okay so this is what it looks like
comparing ngf deprivation to injury if
you take away ngf it takes quite a while
for the axons to look all mangled and
blobby so by 24 hours we get quite a bit
of degeneration and injuring this
happens much faster and in fact we can
quantify that it we've got the NGF
deprivation it takes about 24 hours to
reach the fifty percent degeneration
point but
context of the injury it starts
happening right away the kinetics don't
change as a function of ngf being
present or whether we're using juvenile
or adult neurons but that's not too
pleased sure yeah okay good yeah okay so
we want to compare the relative
contribution of tnf our family members
and development versus injury contents
and what you can see here is that we
just did the same experiment using
neurons from TN FR p75 or gear 6
knockout mice it might be hard to see on
this but we can quantify it here and we
basically see that in the absence of
teen of our neurons to generate just
fine and the absence of p75 they're
protected pretty well it will eventually
degenerate but at the 24-hour time point
they're protected dr6 protects the these
memes are involved in injury induced
degeneration and they also have some
modest protection and this developmental
paradigm any enemy see this night okay
yes good okay yeah so this is this is
what we think is happening in
development dr6 and p75 are working in
parallel to promote degeneration is that
also true in injury and so we can go
back those that also true an injury did
all the same things and then we quantify
it and we see that neither King afar or
p75 is required or injury induced a
generation but dr6 like wo the essence
arm are absolutely essential this is
actually and we did the time course here
and you can see that tr6 really extends
the life of these axons as well as any
known factor involved in degeneration
and we can we can do this in sensory
neurons too so it's not just restricted
to sympathetic neurons but also works in
sensory neurons dr6 is totally
protective but this actually tells us
that maybe development here 6mt
something over both require
but an injury here six is absolutely
essential and I think the fact that
we've got now a receptor in one of the
previous generation its kind of profound
and really is going to change the way we
think about how injury news to
generation occurs any so seeing the Sun
okay okay so we got here we've got a
sciatic nerve injury mouthful so it's
great that we can do this in vitro but
we want to be able to do this in vivo as
well so in this case we basically did a
surgery on animals and clipped the
saitek nerve to cut a chunk of it and
then sewed the animal back up and then
came back two weeks later to watch the
degeneration so this is going to be that
distal part the part towards the toes
the kibbutz's degeneration and what you
can see on the left are is a stain from
Milan so if you see these kind of little
Donuts that means that we've got nice my
linen fibers and then on the right we
got electron microscopy on Android
versus injured what I think you can
appreciate right away is that in
wild-type the nice beautiful axons these
big bundles are nice and intact but in
the injured 14 days later they're
totally trashed so the accents are coat
are completely gone and the asset in
this w LD s mutant or in the absence of
storm the axon state preserved and then
in the absence of dr6 just like what we
saw in vitro we get a pretty good
preservation of the axons what's
interesting here though is that injured
if you look at the bottom right corner
we get a pretty massive loss of my one
okay so there seems to be the axons are
preserved but the myelin is lost which
is kind of a new phenotype in and
suggest that we that these a loss of
Milan and loss of axons are separable
pathways just exciting skippers so
essentially what we found is that dear 6
is required for injuring gusta
generation but the question is does this
also feed into these known pathways like
a junk pathway
so essentially we did our axotomy again
nvivo and then we just make sure that
we're so we did our X out of me again
and 30 minutes after the injury we get a
nice induction of June kinase but in the
dr singh's knockout that's totally gone
so what this indicates is that after
injury we have dr6 feeding into junk
eyes and so maybe maybe what we're maybe
what we are doing is just kind of
expanding the note pathway but we don't
know yet is what the ligand for this
receptor is and we also don't know how
it is that the axon and some eunuch
ating with the schwann cells leo cell
and if whether there's a receptor to
receive that and so with that I will end
and I can take questions if there are
time there's time give out on the screen
share here okay good hey hey so
presentation is done okay good so it was
a nice cup bushings like that those that
you say it like Exxon degenerate sounded
cool and that I like yeah so that like
is that any death receptor or anything
like that yeah so so that was kind of
the main finding is that instead of this
kind of old idea that the axon
degenerates on its own there is the
stuff receptor death receptor six is
absolutely central for the degeneration
of been green eyes it they think that
that would be a dad except that United
him to the death except that like Mark
II found out and get Thank You hewlett I
you know I think that would be really
interesting I mean thus far you know
based on our in vivo model we know here
six is essential for the degeneration of
sensory neuron sympathetic neurons and
motor neurons what we're thinking about
how is whether it's also going to be
essential for degeneration and central
nervous system and so we're doing those
experiments rails
other receptors involved is a really
interesting issue you know anybody but I
the point that I think I fail to make is
that by now knowing that there's a
receptor and probably a ligand for this
it might give us an an explanation for
why it is that we get by standard
degeneration if you have a stroke or
traumatic brain injury if you have a
little region of the brain that is
actually injured why is it that there's
this whole halo around the injury site
that we're working on czar lost also so
this might be providing an explanation
for why you get these by standard
neurons or by standard axons being
degenerated and so in that context I
think it is possible there could be
other receptors involved maybe however
shoppers or something like i don't think
i have immediate a question but it is a
very interesting including the
presentation and I read you a paper to
it is pretty I mean like it is really
something new you are finding out there
and thank you for taking making this
effort to present your work to our
audience and we should put that and
hopefully we will be able to catch you
sometime soon again with some money
publication awesome yeah I was our
pleasure to talk to you I appreciate the
invitation ago thank you okay bye right